the number of deaths linked to fentanyl
overdoses continues to increase
Nationwide including right here in Clark
County former first lady and Secretary
of State Hillary Clinton paid a visit to
a recovery organization here in town
eight news now reporter Joshua peguero
was there and hears from survivors
Madam Secretary Clinton's visit to the
foundation for Recovery highlighted the
opioid epidemic as well as a donation of
more than 20 000 doses of Narcan that
her organization has made five
is the number of young people that bill
and I personally know
who've lost their own lives to overdoses
before a packed crowd of volunteers and
Spectators secretary Clinton said drug
overdose is the leading cause of deaths
for 18 to 45 year olds people in the
prime of their lives just starting out
starting work starting school starting a
family doing you know what we all
imagine you do in those uh key years
data from the Clark County coroner's
office shows that three-quarters of all
of last year's overdose deaths were
linked to fentanyl in 2018 it was just
one in five Rob bankhart along with
other survivors at the event credit
organizations like foundation for
Recovery who hand out doses of narcans
of the homeless we have to meet people
where they're at and I was homeless at
the time using an intent under a bridge
you know I mean so if we had waited for
the EMTs to show up I wouldn't be here
right now Narcan also saved donica's
Martinez's life she says secretary
Clinton's visit makes her feel seen it
shows me that people care that not just
people out here that I live with but
people who are higher up people that
have an influence in a voice actually
care and want to make a difference
starting statistics showed at the event
there were a hundred and ten thousand
overdose deaths last year we're putting
your Charleston indicator Joshua peguero
eight news now
and of those Nationwide death Joshua
mentioned were linked to Fentanyl
Nevada Health District issued a warning
that fentanyl is now being mixed with a
dangerous animal tranquilizer Narcan
cannot reverse the effects of that
mixture